foreign
hi Elena how are you
hi I'm good how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
question so my husband and I are
debating paying off the house
um I know you've had this one before or
investing money she
we're on I think we've completed up the
baby step four now
um he likes to have cash on hand just
you know if the market does go down and
we want to buy another house for
investment purposes
um fully funding but
we're just kind of in the predicament do
we pay off fast now do we pay it off in
chunks like throw a big chunk this year
then another chunk next year
want to get your thoughts
uh how long you been listening to this
show
um a while and he sends me I I think I
know what you're gonna say but I kind of
also let him to hear it
okay I mean if you're going to work our
plan you already know what you're
supposed to do right
if you're going to work your plan then
you get to make up your own plan
right
so but we know from data and 30 years of
doing this the shortest distance
between where you are and wealthy is to
get everything paid off and stop
borrowing money because you get control
of your most powerful wealth building
tool which is your income
and you know the vast majority of the
millionaires that we studied in the
millionaires largest study of
millionaire has ever done had paid off
their home early
and um and it frees up that house
payment I mean when you start investing
a house payment it turns into a million
dollars so fast it's scary
when you were talking about what he
wants to do in terms of investing did
you mention the possibility of getting
another house I thought I heard that
yeah
using the cash on hand to buy a rental
instead of paying off their home
yeah so because we're maxed I mean we
Max our 401ks
um we put money in our roths
so but instead of you know putting all
eggs in one basket that was kind of our
next especially if the market does go
down yeah so you've been listening to
the show for a while has he been
listening for a while or what's kind of
his attitude towards the baby stuff he
he he likes and I laugh when you guys
say you know the feeling of having zero
debt if you do pay it off he just has a
certain dollar threshold that he likes
to see in savings and I think he's just
scared to see that goal of that
um so I think Jesus the comfort of
having cash on hand how much cash have
you got
um
Savings of about three hundred thousand
dollars
uh just is it just sitting in a
high-yield savings account or what what
are y'all doing with the money right now
yeah
yeah that's costing you 2500 bucks a
month right there
opportunity costs that's dumber than a
rock that's not comforting that's just
stupid
how much is your mortgage
um we're on a 15-year it's about what's
your balance
oh 205. pay it off today
now this is ridiculous you'd still have
a ton of money left you're still sitting
on a hundred thousand dollars what is it
makes you comfortable my God
pay that off today
you're sitting there making one percent
on your money
and calling that comfortable
no no no
what do you guys make you must make five
or six hundred thousand what do you make
no um like four yeah I figured Lord
honey y'all do whatever you want to do
but you called here
um
yeah this is your your situation
financial planners uh worldwide would
call you ridiculous sitting on 300 Grand
cash at one percent
I mean I I don't think you're going to
find anybody who goes oh that's wise
um I mean I I like having cash around I
believe in liquidity I believe in having
an emergency fund I believe in having
access to your money but um yeah that
you guys need to write a check today Hey
listen pay it off and if you hate it you
hate being debt free with only a hundred
thousand in the bank in four or five
months just go get you another mortgage
you'll feel better
you'll never do that by the way once you
pay it off you're gonna go oh I was
completely getting my that was just no
way I'm going back right well and they
make they asked earlier what the numbers
were oh I'm like they make enough money
they could buy that rental property soon
they can get the bank account back up
soon I'm like hacking my brain you make
400k you can buy another rental by the
end of the year in cash
and not and never have any debt
I mean you're sitting on a hundred
thousand dollars after we do this deal
you need to pay this house off
before that's
that's Merry Christmas
do it right now
oh my gosh I think I think that's a good
word gosh that's yeah my brain is like
I'm racking my brain trying to think
through any reasons or arguments that he
might have
that are valid there's naughty they're
not that this is just
what what happens in this situation is
the kids they make a lot of money I knew
it I could smell it well you make five
six hundred oh just 400 okay yeah wow
okay so they make a ton of money and
they work like crazy people they work
hard they put a lot of hours in probably
carrying a lot of stress
and the that pile of money does give you
comfort
when you're working that hard because
you can if anything if you just want to
do something just do it the it gives you
lots of options and margin and that kind
of thing and so what he's receiving from
that is a comfort it is an emotional
Comfort but what you're trading it for
is the emotional discomfort of losing 30
to 40 000 a year return on 300 Grand
sitting there doing nothing
I mean 40 000 bucks a year is
substantial loss that's huge you know
and uh I mean thirty thousand at or 300
000 at ten percent thirty thousand so I
mean whatever you want to calculate it
at but thirty thousand that's that's
that that's that's serious money and
that's a nice vacation I'm just saying
that's a nice vacation and so what what
it's a lot of things what what you don't
realize when you're in a situation and
Elena's situation is
um that the comfort and the margin and
the flexibility that all that cash gives
you intellectually
the trade-off is emotionally you haven't
realized you are carrying weight with
that mortgage and you have you just kind
of set it in the back of your mind but
it's still in your mind and as Dr
Delaney talks about your body knows that
it's there
and so when you pay this off you're
going to get a different kind of peace
that is actually more thorough I'm a
more thorough piece than you're getting
from this pile of cash the cash is a
mirage that's what I'm saying